i love do i think the stage is my first
love yeah
you know followed by the movies and
television and then my family
and i find
but i find that it is filled fraught
with frightening experiences i was in
baltimore five years ago
and the worst thing that could ever
happen to a human being happened
i was in this beautiful suite and had a
kind of foyer
from the one door and then there's a
little hallway and then
here and there the new york times was
there and i was naked
uh buck naked as we say in porn
and and uh
and i went to get the new york times i
was naked and i go and i hear
and i realized that the door has closed
behind me
seriously yeah and it's just like out of
the movies i am now naked
in a hallway big hallway in the big bowl
this is everyone's
greatest fear yeah and so um i picked up
i picked up the new york times and
luckily it was a sunday time so i was
like but i and wayne's uh
you full coverage yeah and way down the
hallway
i could see a maid's kind of uh
you know stand and so i thought well she
must be down there's no one in the
hallway
so i like walked down well i didn't walk
like that way but i kind of walked down
the hallway with the paper in front of
me
and then i went excuse me
hello i'm saying and a guy opens the
door beside
the door she's working on he kind of
goes
jerry lewis was staying at your hotel
wow
but then but then so she comes out and
the cleaning the cleaning staff person
sees me
she looks at me and just looks up and
down says mr short you have made my day
downside or the upside